on voyons tout de suite les principales
réactions politiques qui nous sont
parvenus aujourd'hui le sentiment
général c'est d'abord de la
reconnaissance pour ceux qui ont permis
la libération des otages de part et
d'autre on exclut toute récupération
politique de l'événement
écoutons j'ai entendu le débat télévisé
où le président de la république a dit à
quelles conditions les otages pouvaient
être libérés
monsieur le premier ministre a dit qu'il
en était d'accord je n'ai donc aucune
raison de penser que des concessions
étaient faites lorsque monsieur pasqua
s'exprime je l'entends et je me dis s'il
dit vrai alors tout est bien pour la
france sur le plan personnel comme
citoyen comme individu je me réjouis de
la fin de l'épreuve de ces malheureux et
de l'angoissé leurs familles mais sur le
plan politique comme politique
je trouve que la méthode discussions
avec les organisations terroristes est
condamnable
il ya trois ans qu'ils aient des détenus
depuis trois ans jour pour jour nous
luttons pour que s'ouvrent des
négociations
enfin ces négociations abouties nous
sommes heureux de saluer leur courage et
de leur souhaiter bon retour dans leur
famille et dans la communauté nationale
oui tout